[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la atención política
entre Colombia y Guatemala esto después
de que la fiscalía especial contra la
impunidad guatemalteca acusará al
ministro de defensa colombiano hablamos
de Iván Velázquez esto de haber
permitido
supuestamente acuerdos de cooperación
con directivos de la constructora
odebrecht cuando era jefe de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en ese
país centroamericano esto entre 2013 y
el año 2017 saludamos en este momento a
nuestro primer invitado del día él es
Juan Francisco Sandoval ex fiscal de
guatemalteco en el exilio fue auxiliar
fiscal segundo el trabajo también con
Iván Velázquez y su último cargo fue el
de jefe de la fiscalía especial contra
la impunidad Gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 Juan y pues le quiero preguntar a
primeramente su opinión sobre todo este
caso y que ocurre realmente hay otro
tipo de motivaciones tras de este caso
contra Velázquez
Muchísimas gracias bueno primero
comentar que
el anuncio que realizó el actual jefe de
la fiscalía especial contra la impunidad
en Guatemala responde a un patrón que
hemos venido denunciando desde hace
alrededor de cinco años donde la
rearticulación de políticos y la élite
empresarial corrupta de Guatemala que
fue desnudada o fueron desnudados sus
actos ilícitos con las acciones que
lideró de parte de la excomisionado Iván
Velázquez al rearticularse lo que están
realizando es un acto o una serie de
actos de venganza que para la fecha
tiene una cauda de 30 operadores de
Justicia
guatemaltecos en el exilio Diez de los
operadores de Justicia procesados
existen presos de conciencia existe
persecución para la prensa independiente
que ha denunciado estos hechos y en
contra de activistas sociales por lo que
esta es una acción más dentro de un
patrón que ha sido establecido ya por el
sistema interamericano Al haber colocado
a Guatemala en el capítulo 4b que
corresponde a los estados que violan
gravemente los derechos humanos en este
caso específicamente para este segmento
Que investigó los casos de Gran
corrupción en Guatemala y eso también
viene de la pasada administración no
llamada la atención que desde el pasado
presidente Jimmy Morales pues está pues
ocurriendo todo esto también ahorita con
Alejandro yamatei ya este pues este
impase no entre el gobierno colombiano y
el gobierno guatemalteco también escaló
a otro nivel Llamando a sus Embajadores
Como pudiera terminar a todo este roce
político Juan
bueno de parte del gobierno de Guatemala
como vemos las posturas son
contradictorias e irracionales porque
por una parte llama la Concordia Pero
por otro lado ofende no solo al
presidente colombiano sino desde el día
en que fue designado Iván Velázquez como
ministro de la defensa de Colombia el
gobierno de Guatemala dejó sin efecto un
acuerdo suscrito entre los ejércitos de
Guatemala y de Colombia entonces parece
que aquí el tema es más de índole
política que jurídica pero se
instrumentaliza la fiscalía guatemalteca
para realizar este tipo de acciones y es
que en Guatemala lo que existen
actualmente es una democracia
supuesta en realidad es una democracia
pero Lo que esconde en ese disfraz es
una dictadura el actual gobernante que
ante en el Perú de Pedro castillo y se
convirtió en el más impopular de América
Latina pero tiene Bajo su control todas
las instituciones del estado el poder
judicial por ejemplo los magistrados del
actual Corte Suprema de Justicia que han
prolongado sus funciones casi cuatro
años y los y quiénes eligieron a estos
magistrados son los dos principales
señalados en las investigaciones del
caso odebrecht allá se descubrió que el
soborno correspondía a un monto de
alrededor de veinte millones de dólares
y los máximos beneficiarios de esos
sobornos Alejandro sinibaldi y Manuel
baldizón son quienes además de haber
impuesto a la Corte Suprema de Justicia
actual son los principales beneficiados
con este caso donde lejos de perseguir
la operación transnacional de lavado de
activos lo que se está haciendo es
perseguir a quienes descubrimos tales
hechos eso eso le quería preguntar no
qué teme actual le mandatario Alejandro
yamatei con la información sensible que
que pueda tener el actual ministro
colombiano Velázquez que recordemos como
lo dijimos al principio pues trabajó en
toda esta investigación y este entramado
de corrupción en Guatemala no que
pudiera ventilar no de alguna manera y
qué secretos le puede también revelar al
gobierno colombiano Velázquez Bueno en
realidad existe una sed de venganza
recordemos que cuando Iván Velázquez no
fungía como comisionado de la cistid
dicho organismo en colaboración con el
Ministerio Público descubrió una trama
de ejecuciones extrajudiciales en la que
uno de los principales involucrados en
el actual presidente de Guatemala
Quién fue sustraído de la pesquisa por
la ayuda que brindó Carol Patricia
flores Polanco quien fue la juez que
emitió las órdenes de captura sobre las
que el actual jefe de la fe Si en
Guatemala yo o publicó un video anteayer
en vídeo fue donde realizó un
señalamiento directo en contra del
ministro de la defensa de Colombia puede
ser un motivo correspondiente a una
eventual venganza y la otra situación
está relacionada En qué la fiscalía
especial contra la impunidad cuando yo
la dirigí encaminó tus acciones a
establecer que en por lo menos tres
casos había corrupción en el gobierno de
Alejandro yamatei y meses después yo fui
destituido Entonces esto corresponde a
un plan si usted O sí los medios de
comunicación internacional realizaran
una investigación hemerográfica de cómo
han evolucionado los acontecimientos en
Guatemala es todo un plan todo un plan
de venganza y un plan de rearticulación
de actores corruptos en Guatemala Juan
por parte del gobierno del presidente
guatemalteco
llamatei asegura que hubo
irregularidades en el trabajo de
Velázquez en Guatemala qué
irregularidades se refiere llamate
bueno primero no sería propio que
Alejandro es matei hablara de
irregularidades cometidas por Iván
Velázquez tomando en consideración de
que
Alejandro yamataino formaba parte del
sistema judicial obviamente por haber
sido señalado directamente por la
comisión puede tener alguna
inconformidad y Como creo que es normal
que cualquier persona que se siente
señalada manifiesta inconformidad con
respecto a las acciones que emprende
quien lo señala
Juan ya para para ir terminando nuestra
conversación Cómo va a terminar no todo
este caso de corrupción este tipo de
señalamientos también que salpican al
presidente guatemalteco Alejandro
yamatei y cómo puede Cómo pueden saber
los guatemaltecos realmente la verdad no
una verdad A lo mejor objetiva cómo
buscarla no entre acusaciones
contradictorias de un lado y el otro
Bueno yo creo que el pueblo de Guatemala
en el fondo sabe la verdad porque lo que
logramos nosotros descubrir no fue Solo
este caso sino que tres ex gobernantes
están enfrentando actualmente la
justicia
se lograron grandes avances en temas
relacionados con reparación con el
descubrimiento de estructuras criminales
enquistadas en el estado y
la respuesta del poder corrupto que
gobierna Guatemala es esta que muchos
estemos en el exilio que existan
detenidos de conciencia y que este
conflicto
escale a este nivel
y que lo que esperamos Quién es por
hacer nuestro trabajo nos encontramos
hoy exiliados es que la comunidad
internacional
tome medidas tome acciones porque en
Guatemala existe una justicia totalmente
tomada por estas estructuras criminales
las personas quienes deben enfrentar
justicia deben de enfrentarse a casos
basados en prueba implantada ayer hacían
entrevistas en medios colombianos y al
fiscal guatemalteco no pudo dar ninguna
respuesta con respecto a cuál es en
realidad son los señalamientos en contra
del ex comisionado Velázquez Claro que
en realidad se trata de humo para
desprestigiar